Okay,
we are back live.
Hi.
Probably should change the uh the stream
title a little bit. You know what? Nah,
leave it for today.
been in too much stuff lately.
Far far too much stuff.
They just need to get back to
core improvements on puffer and uh maybe
some applications.
I think what we're going to do today
number of different things.
The material science stuff is uh the
most at the moment.
I would like to at least get that to a
point we have some sort of interesting
demo.
That's what we'll right now.
Hey, Anic.
Two player turnbased game. Uh oh. Uh
have you figured out that uh the
turnbased stuff is a little tricky in
Puffer?
Most of the time we at least we script.
We just like have a scripted opponent
play one side. Pure infrastructure
problem, mind you. Something I plan on
messing with soon.
Hard to email how good this kind of
works.
Gladly take a look at that at some
point.
Trying to remember where we left off
with this.
See if I had this like basic material
science sim.
It's not your turn. Your action just
doesn't do anything.
Uh that is actually a decent way around
it for now.
Like of all the dumb solutions, I think
that's probably the
uh most reasonable.
So, good job on that.
Okay, so here's a particle sim.
Got a bunch of particles buzzing around.
go to point model or whatever.
The next thing we were going to try to
do is actually
have these things be evaluated based on
speific properties. Right?
What you're trying to model this is
material science stuff.
We're hooking up Puffer to a a material
science sim and we're going to see if we
can steer atoms into useful materials.
Kind of funny.
I uh I got to go grab my phone actually
because I think that the the guy who
I've been chatting with on this will DM
to me. One second.
Okay.
Thing that I've been suggested to do,
welcome builder. Thing I've been
suggested to do is to go find um the
thermal conductivity
stuff and lamps.
Leonard Jones. Okay.
Thermal conductivity is a measure of the
propensity of material to trans energy
by for Huh?
First method is to set up two thermostat
regions opposite ends of aation.
Holding the two different temperature
setting
to the hot the energy cold
thing I've never seen before. I I don't
know what that is.
There like sample of this somewhere.
Trying to see if you have to change the
sim in order to measure
flux can be calculated from the
fluctuation per atom potential.
potential
steady state
Okay, I think this is what we want,
right? Because this is steady state.
So like we can just calculate this at
any given time.
The thing is they don't they don't have
great API docs as far as I can tell. Oh,
Then I I don't know if this is going to
give me potentially point or what.
We'll have to see how this works.
Worth playing with a little bit today
though, right?
Why do you use Brock among LLMs? because
I don't use LLMs that much. So, it
really doesn't matter.
I really don't need to switch between
all the LMS when they leaprog each other
every other month.
As you can see, I'm basically using it
to find docks.
I should at least check to see if it is
here. I don't think it is here.
I guess I guess it is kind of just like
command level, right?
Amps command.
Yeah. So, it kind of just does execute
command strings.
Define a computation. Calculate flux
vector
contribution atoms in the specified
group.
This can be used by itself to measure
the heat flux through a set of atoms
or to calculate thermal conductivity.
I think this is what we want is thermal
conductivity.
We have two body interaction. What is
this?
Ideas of other comput atom kinetic
energy per atom potential
per atom strength.
Hi. Where
where are you at in environment.
Um, I'm trying to figure out how to
comput thermal conductivities.
probably wasn't the smartest thing for
me to do today. I really need to be uh
quite fresh for something that's
complicated. But at least we'll give
this a little bit of time and if I don't
make any progress on this, I'll switch
to something. Okay.
Okay. So, it's pretty much they're just
pasting in
all these cans.
What is this? is
tracked thermal conductivity.
This is so far just setting up
atoms.
Equilibrium and calibration trying to
get an equilibrium state I believe. Put
a bunch of argan atoms. They should put
themselves into a I suppose
and compute
IP address
blocks
DZ.
Okay. So, this is
why they have to do all of this.
This is like a weird
I I think LAMPs just has a really
bizarro interface. The fact that it's
parsing
string commands like this, it's just
does not have a proper exposed API,
right?
I'm going to like just play with this a
little bit. I thank you.
Still trying to figure out mentally how
this stuff works, right?
ID group ID.
Flash flux style name
AE ID ID of calculates per atom connect
ID ID of calculates per atom potential
energy stress ID calculates per atom
stress. This will give us per atom
Okay. So do
X Y and Z
flux vector.
So this is going to give you vector
field then right
this taking so long. I think that I what
I want to do right is I want to figure
out how to evaluate this render these
vectors
then like either maximize this and
minimize kinetic energy or like
something like that, right?
Can you read what the uh this material
scientist sent me again?
eight atoms
doesn't tell us what type of atoms we're
making, right?
non-interacting particle. Okay.
Want to change this
This is why the atoms weren't
interacting at all before.
I literally have a comment there that I
ignored
one one point. I already have this right
up just heck of it.
atoms will repel if too close.
But we want
preced velocities correctly overriding
natural MD.
But we need equilibrium dynamics without
external.
Well, it doesn't understand what I'm
trying to do here, right? I'm trying to
get them to a state
function starts from the current
velocity uh position velocity
velocities.
That's such a weird word. It's
equilibrium and calibrate, right?
liberates
Yes. I mean, it's actually kind of funny
because this gave me the thing that this
gave me is like roughly the way that you
would typically view simulation. Is not
like this is not like an uncommon
unreasonable thing it gave me, but it
doesn't make any bloody sense for RL,
right?
We're not going to do it the correct
traditional way and like just have the
RL hard fail, right? We're going to do
it the way that makes sense for RL if
the thing we get out of it is at all
physically reasonable.
Important that we do it this way.
Yeah, I also don't need to save this
state.
My camera frozen.
Lovely.
Uh maybe I just unplug and replplug
camera real quick once.
Well, that's weird.
What's wrong with camera?
Nothing here.
Okay. Well,
Bizarro
Dang it. Well,
I guess my camera is just dead. Unless I
find some quick way to fix this.
Oh,
okay. Well, it's completely messed up,
but
we'll do uh
do this. I guess
we'll see if that happens again.
Computer's kind of old.
Also, Windows is terrible.
Partial equalation
proxy comput.
scientist time again. Yep. Oh, I forgot
to ban that bot. Hang on.
I don't understand why I have to
manually be computing integral uh
integrals.
The hell is this?
No, I shouldn't have to do this. This is
making crap up.
Why you don't use LMS for stuff? They're
very stupid.
Um
just it's annoying because we don't have
good docks around this, right?
I guess we have this.
What is puffer advantage in puffer lib?
It is a strict generalization of
generalized advantage estimation in B
trace.
so for some stupid reason this
implemented trapezoidal rule manually.
This is basically from their dock. So
this is fine.
I actually think this is all kind of
fine.
Um, I'm just steering step.
I actually I want to put this before run
one do like
a total flux vector. It is not for each
atoms.
Is there not any like reasonable measure
I can get
per atom out of this?
Like I need some sort of localized
metric, right?
Like is it not a vector? Is the thermal
conductivity not a vector field that we
should just be able to evaluate at each
atom? Is that not how it works?
evaluated at each position technically.
Okay.
What this is
this is this is per atom
And instead of this,
do this. Right.
The thing is this is not an API, right?
The fact that I'm writing C is
irrelevant at the moment, it's like
janky because this is actually just a
wrapper around this like opaque command
parser in with strings.
guess this will we need this for a delta
flux, right?
What time is it over there? It is
1:45.
I really should have not chosen to do
this today.
Like
Are you working on uh material science
simulation for reinforcement learning?
Trying to get some thermal
conductivities evaluated.
Okay. So this is fine because this is
now this is registered, right?
So we actually we don't need any of this
stuff anymore, right?
Do we
steering setup?
No, we don't. We literally just need
Okay, so this is better then because
this gives us what we actually need.
Don't need all this crap.
You're going to include thermodynamics,
temperature.
Uh I'm going to play with more things as
I understand what the heck is going on.
The initial goal is to just get atoms to
steer themselves into a configuration
that produces some property we care
about, right?
Atoms to steer themselves into a
thermally conductive configuration or
likelative
configuration, something basic like
that.
See if I can get anything working and we
can go we can do stuff from there. I
just want to see this do something
meaningful.
Apparently get allocated for some dumb
reason.
And what else?
A run command somewhere.
on command needs to go here
be able to extract after the
Hey Joseph might be a noob question any
plans lead directions on robotics and
puffer recently moved back to robotics
and RL from theory and I've been meaning
to add something puffer yes so uh right
now we are doing low fidelity control of
our own we're doing drones some point I
will want to do a freedom arm
One guy spoke to an SF who may or may
not be working on it already. If you
post in the Discord, you might be able
to find him. Um, but yeah, that's
something we would like to do have like
our own from scratch.
Um, let's see. uh for bindings to
existing stuff. Uh if you have robotics
background, we have a beta like very
basic manny skill binding I set up
looking at and it's pretty much just a
matter of like can we actually make
puffer be fast and pain manny skill even
though their sims are not anywhere fast
as our our puffer sim.
Okay. So, let's see if this does
anything.
applying zero offset null point.
So this didn't get should somehow
find person on Discord. I can actually
find I have a Twitter DM. Let me find
it.
Um,
I'll link his X.
Yeah. So this thing is null somehow.
Not register this
and paste this entire thing in.
And this is like a weird
like this is the thing with using
packages that work this way.
I have to talk to um material scientist
better one because it's like really not
written in the way you would want. It's
like they say they have a C API, but
this is not a C API. This is like a
wrapper over the SL.
I suppose that eventually like these
things get parsed into function
lamps. You can probably just call
get into it.
All right. Does anybody know why this
thing is messed up?
Um, and also, well, I guess it's double
precision's probably standard for this
stuff, huh?
Not that bad. Not that bad. It's still
vision not GP.
variable formula cannot be
variable wait formula
not be invoked initialize. How's this
make any sense?
That has ever lived ever in the history
of programmers. Here's why I like lens.
The reason I love Hi. Hi.
Hi.
>> Oh, green light.
>> The reason I love LLMs is because it
allows me to write code faster. And what
this in turn does is it gives me
more opportunities to Hey, Joseph, hit
that hit that mother.
Hit that [ __ ] button, dude. Hit
that request to speak button. Hit it
right now. I got 15 minutes.
I might be the best programmer that's
ever existed in the history of mankind.
>> I might be the best programmer. Oh,
hello Sensei. How's it going? Everyone,
everyone click click click that mother.
Everyone click that follow button right
now on Joseph Wires. Click that follow
button as soon as possible. Everyone
click that follow button right now.
Click click click that follow button.
>> Hello.
>> Hey, I think this works.
Yeah,
>> I was streaming Material Science Dev and
I saw you have this most bait possible
space.
>> Yeah, it's perfect. It's It's I'm really
good at clickbait. You know how I my
secret to clickbait. The reason people
get so infuriated is because the I
actually really believe it and that's
what gets people like they know that I'm
not mean. They know it's real. Like
that's what really annoys people. Like
you could say something that's not real
and people won't take you seriously. But
as soon as as soon as you really mean
it, like you're I mean really do think
I'm right now at this very moment. I do
feel like I'm the best programmer in the
world. Um all thanks to you and your and
your glorious software that I've been
copying. Uh it's it's been very very
helpful actually.
>> Well, I'm definitely not the best
programmer and I wrote Puffer Live.
>> No, you're probably close to probably
the best programmer ever ever in the
world. You're probably pretty close.
>> I've met I've met a few people who are
very very good late. Um, it's just it's
honestly it's just that
>> like the bar that's set by a lot of the
big tech companies, you have to dig for
it.
>> Yeah, it's true.
It's true. I mean, like also like being
a good programmer isn't necessarily
rewarded at like big tech companies.
Like at the end of the day, like the the
way I define a good programmer is like
who's someone who is really good at
managing complexity and not making
things more complex than they need to.
>> Solving solving
complicated problems with simple
solutions that are easy to understand
and easy to change.
>> And I think that's not necessarily
rewarded, right? If you do things in a
simple manner, then you actually become
less more replaceable, right? which is
actually a good thing for the system
overall, but not good for you
personally.
>> Yeah. So, this is why you just ignore
these dumb incentive structures because
get nothing done.
>> Yes, exactly. Um I've been getting a lot
more done after I left my job, let me
tell you. Or after I was forcibly
removed from my job. Um I've been
getting a lot of done a lot done. I had
uh my first sim to real success today,
by the way, just about like 30 minutes
ago.
>> Do you know Do you want to know what the
last bug was?
>> Yeah. You had to Didn't you literally
have Was it like an accelerometer or
something that was sideways?
>> Yeah, my Yeah, my accelerometer was like
the wrong orientation.
>> You know, I've actually You could
technically you could technically make
it so that it would still be able to fly
that way.
>> Yeah. I I I was honestly getting so
pissed
about like the random like the like
trying to figure out orientation through
the three different nodes I was I was
managing. Yeah, I agree. Uh the three
different modes I was nodes I was
managing. I I I seriously consider just
adding like domain randomization on like
the control stick channels and like
letting it figure it out. But what I
noticed with uh so I mean right now I'm
using uh
>> yes I mean it would it would actually
work too
actually work. Um so my setup right now
is I I'm doing the simplest I mean I'm
doing the simplest thing possible which
is I have an ESP32 on the device. It's
sending back the data over over the air
to my to my control system and that's
outputting the control inputs to I've I
basically hacked a bunch of [ __ ] to to
to do this. I mean it it actually works
like the the the thing I was like really
struggling with I think yesterday. So
before yesterday, I learned all about
reward design where I
uh I learned all about reward design
about like the difference between sparse
rewards and dense rewards. And I
actually like took it to practice like I
actually like you know change the
difference like dense reward versus
sparse reward, negative versus positive.
And I had the model do things like
suicide to pre to prevent the punishment
that was too severe for it. And the
thing I realized was just get I mean
like my my general rule of thumb that
I've developed now is give it give it
sparse rewards and modulate the rewards
every set of steps and the set of steps
need to be more than the horizon of the
l the long-term short-term network. Um
the long whatever whatever it's [ __ ]
that's an awful name. Um but the
recurrent like the recurrent neural
network you need to make the rate at
which the rewards are given longer than
its horizon so that the you force the
neural network to learn how to keep
state between different like beyond its
actual horizon if that makes sense.
Uh yeah, there actually I've had a bunch
of people annoyed with that. There are
some approximations we make that can
potentially mess some stuff up with that
with puffer, but also just the kind of
hard for the LSMs to actually remember
that far back.
>> Um I did you did you see the way that I
did my dense rewards for the drones?
>> I've not looked at that. I I think you
had like episode return increasing over
time.
>> Okay. Everyone does dense rewards wrong
and most of the material you're going to
read about it is wrong. Um,
>> okay.
>> It's like dramatically better to do
deltas than it is to just do like state
based.
>> The state based would be like,
>> okay,
>> you know, one minus my distance to the
goal, right? That's a state-based
reward.
>> You should instead do how much closer am
I to my goal this step versus last step.
That's a delta of the same information,
right?
>> It gives you a much larger dynamic.
naturally just
>> you cut out.
>> I think I've
actually ended up doing it like that for
wars in general. It's like they're
always delta based.
>> Well, that's how we had it originally.
How how yeah
dead zone in my in Ottawa Ontario. Do
you know about Ottawa Ontario? It's a
lot like Maryland which is where you're
from. Goonies where I
>> Where the heck even is I'm at I'm at
Alberta. I don't know. You're not going
to RLC, right?
It's in Canada.
>> Oh man, I wish I was. Dude, I really
wish I was.
>> Yeah, it's in Canada. I really do wish I
was going. I I really need to haul ass
on this [ __ ] right now, but
>> uh I think maybe next year I'll come. I
want to do is open sauce and the art
opera.
>> Yeah, RLC is like a really small one. I
haven't been to it before, but I like
Puffer got accepted, so whatever. I got
to go and present.
>> That's awesome. Congrats. Thank
>> It's like so dated at this point because
it's 20, but whatever.
Um,
>> yes.
>> Yeah. Anyways, I cool to see you're
getting the thing running on
>> I'm in the zone right now.
>> Ah, yeah.
It's cool to see you're getting stuff
running hardware though.
>> I got Finn and Sam doing that on like
stuff. Got to
>> do it. I mean, this is the worst.
>> Hey guys, how's it going? You hear me?
>> Oh, hey Bat.
>> Hey, I'm in the car just heading heading
heading home from work actually. Pretty
good. Uh, wow. This is pretty
incredible. Joseph got seen jank audio
as always. Probably phones on low
battery too. Uh,
>> but I saw I saw Yaxi in here with this
complete bait title, so I jumped in to
troll him and then he ended up being
nice. So, I was like, "All right, we'll
be nice."
>> Oh, he's No, he's a he's a real troll
guy. I, you know, I was I I thought I
thought No. So, it baited me, too,
because I saw that I saw that you were
It says you were in the space. I'm like,
"What? Joseph would never put a title
like that." Like, like I know he's
really good at programming, but
I was I was confused and this is pretty
cool. Uh
um
>> wait, did I see Finn in here?
>> I hope so. Where is Where is Finn? Let
me know.
>> Oh no, he's going to see me messing
around here instead of helping him with
his drone stuff, though. I don't think
he's messaged me yet.
>> He's probably doing uh either on a on a
holiday or uh flying a drone. One of the
two.
>> Wait, did somebody make us lunar lander?
>> Yeah. Yeah. You haven't you haven't been
picking up on the uh
>> uh Yeah. Lunar lander is a real thing.
Uh um it wasn't landing last time last
time we we checked. It was uh spinning
uncontrollably and bouncing like
crazily.
>> Yeah, that's
you you you know what's wrong already?
>> Well, no. I just like it's a simple end,
but I can fix it. Sure.
I remember a rocket rocket lander.
Rocket lander still. Anyone wants to to
contribute to puffer lid,
>> please please
land a rocket.
>> Interesting.
>> I was measuring latency between like my
control system and the feedback from my
MPU sensor.
>> I realized that like just adding domain
randomization to the delta time is
enough for it to learn how to deal with
latency.
>> Yeah, that's kind of what we were going
to do as well. So I basically I have
this theory that like all of hardware
robotics plus RL is being done wrong
because everybody's trying to just like
model the most accurate thing they
possibly can and failing and making it
slow. You don't need to do that. You
just need to randomize the heck out of
it and make it fast.
>> Um yes. Now the problem though,
>> uh this will work for drones. I think
we'll get it to work for Six Degree of
Freedom Arms at some point when I get
around to either doing that or having a
contributor make that sim. Uh, it's a
hard one, but if anybody wants to take a
crack at it, be my guest. Um, I stuff
like humanoids will be harder because
you kind of actually need to do real
physics. U, but I think that like
humanoids are kind of lame anyways. So,
if we just do arms really well, that'll
already be good.
>> Uh, Joseph, how do I get involved? Say I
want say I want to contribute.
>> Okay. Yeah. Bets our resident advertiser
here. I try not to advertise on Yakian's
face, but it's all at puffer.ai.
>> Yeah,
>> puffer.ai the best reinforcement
learning library in the world. Code that
just makes sense and it immediately
works out of the box. You can learn by
just editing the code. Code direct
double buffering magic. Wow.
>> Yeah,
>> it's true. It's true. Otherwise, you
know, I didn't I we didn't say anything
to to him. He just he just he just
looked at the file. He literally looked
at the one file that does like just
about everything like in a very sane and
very concise manner. He just looked at
it like oh my god this is a revelation.
>> I mean like it it's actually was pretty
difficult to even find that
I mean I didn't know I haven't haven't
trained model that much before now just
playing around with stuff and I was
getting like I was basically touching
and like trying to work with that and
like jacks and stuff. Um, when I found
like when I found like
>> I was able to like make make so much
faster progress like really just having
everything in one place and being able
to read it and like step through it with
a print.
>> The crazy thing is I know exactly how to
make it 10 times better as well. Just
I'm getting bogged down by all the uh
the recent work on you know building out
other applications, contracts and stuff
like that. But I will be back to doing
core dev pretty.
>> So like what were you thinking to like
increase that? I I 100% believe you. I'm
looking at like my GPU util and like I'm
coming up with ideas like okay like
probably this could probably be faster
here and there. Um but what what are you
like planning to do?
>> I mean there are kind of two things. One
is core algorithms just are not where
they need to be yet. Um there's been so
much research done on core algos but
it's all done on really slow ends and
really really dicey experimental setups.
So we have to go back to that. There
have been some recent pubs that I'm I
think have a decent chance of working.
So there's that aspect. And then the
other big thing is just like can compute
MFU and see that the GPU is nowhere near
P. Uh it's just nobody optimizes for
these really small models. Um there's a
lot of info we have to do to actually
get these running at near P. Puffer
could easily be 10 million steps per
second. It could probably be 20 million
steps per second. Right.
>> Yes.
And then if you can do that, then it's
like you're just training on pabytes on
one GPU at that point.
>> I mean, I can't like begin to like, you
know, the most the highest value
returns. My baby's my baby's having
competition here. Um, but
he's currently he's currently trying to
back my car.
the highest value return was like just
being able to see your results so
quickly back and like being able to run
many different experiments
>> because at the end of the day experiment
that you're going to run depends on the
previous experiment that you've already
run. So being able to close the
development, the sequential development
is how you make progress. And for me
like I I wouldn't have been able to make
this progress if I didn't find
infrastructure to learn the exact so
that I could myself gain the experience
be able to do.
>> Yeah. Well, the dev cycle's got to come
down, I think, even more because right
now it's only short for very simple
problems. Uh it's still too long for
like medium complexity problems.
There are two things that go to that
though, right? So there's making the
thing faster, but also just poor
algorithm progress also helps. I mean,
the problems that we take on now is
relatively out of the box required a lot
of hand tuning just one version ago.
Of course, I actually have to find the
time to like sit down and do all that
work.
>> How's how's contracting going? You
making the big bucks now?
>> We've gotten quite a few leads. I I'm
pretty much the goal is to stay in
California till we have something
sizable signed. Um well, like I like the
current contracts are going fine and uh
we have like plenty of leads for
potentially bigger ones. Haven't signed
anything yet though.
Remember man, freedom is the ultimate
thing. Okay? without freedom. Like the
most important thing like I would rather
take like a 20 like a 25% pay cut
because holy moly this kid
the car.
There we go. Problem solved.
the uh I mean there's also the aspect
right of the way of getting more and
more people especially from industry
interested in all these tools is to show
results not just on simple game tasks
right but also on bunch of things across
various different industries whether
it's robotics control or logistics
material science tons of possible
applications
The current thing I'm doing is I'm
hooking Puffer up to lamps material
science sim. I'm trying to get atoms to
steer themselves into arrangements that
produce specific thermal conductivity
patterns.
>> True. Designing environments is
definitely a tail. Like the more you do
it, the better you get. And I feel like
it's so generally applicable that I'm
I'm so much surprised at how well.
>> All right, see you around, man. I'm
going to get back to uh back to free. It
was real.
All
right.
>> All right. See you on the stream,
Joseph.
>> Yep. Bye.
Literally just starts a random space
while uh driving back driving from one
place to another.
change ends.
These don't need to be double star
Isn't it kind of silly that it's built
this way?
Like why is it just why is this thing
parsing commands as strings and
producing invalid states and such,
right? Just be able to call these things
as functions like get errors. They don't
run exactly at the spot where they
break.
Not like set the whole state up and try
to run everything. Have no idea what
happened.
Why? It's every single time it's like
big package someions.
Oh, my bad something. So, let me see. Is
it possible that use one of your
environments instead of let it learn
completely force it to show how it's
doing in time like after region
Oh uh the easiest way to do that is to
just eval different checkpoints.
Set the checkpoint frequency. You can
set it to like to checkpoint very
frequently. Then you can just run eval
on a bunch of different checkpoints to
kind of see how the behaviors change.
API thing is broken. Yeah,
I kind of just want to get something
basic running on this and then I can
chat with material scientist about if
there's a better thing we can use.
It's also possible that I can go into
the lamps internals and just like find
these functions,
but it's not really part of how it's
supposed to work.
A reset thing.
What's this?
Or initialization by a run.
How the heck is that a thing?
working my thesis had this question. So
checkpoints a set amount of steps. So I
can set it. It's a set amount of steps
but it is configurable. You can change
it in the config.
heck is this, man? Why does it work this
way? I just It's like very difficult for
me to even figure out how I'm supposed
to be thinking about this. So wonky.
It's like this domain specific language.
We kind of set up all these commands and
then it's supposed to just run and
populate variables.
But um
when it breaks, there's nothing to debug
because it's just like this massive
command block.
No trace.
Like, are you just supposed to run it
for more of these?
Yeah, this package like it makes it very
very difficult figure out what's going
on with the way it's structured.
The double stuff is irrelevant.
Reset
this just need to be
I don't this this doesn't do anything
right.
This is a handle as well.
just kind of like it's kind of just
flailing. It doesn't know either. Right.
I guess technically if this thing is
wrong
not doing something ridiculous, right?
No.
Do I not have to just like run the
compute command?
I like haven't run the compute command.
Is it that just like this doesn't get
done by run?
uh they are per atoms components of a
flux vector.
I have the command defined. Look, I have
these commands defined up top. This is
supposed to be like some approximation
to local flux,
thermal flux.
I have this
defined here.
Whatever the output of this is,
I would think this is supposed to just
run whenever you call run, right? It
just defines just does everything in
your graph or no.
Or do I have to like manually invoke
these somehow?
big C++ package that doesn't have um
interface for it. Not just this
script thing kind of a mess.
okay, this run. So, you're supposed to
do this
helping,
So it's it's not even in the list of
error messages. Yeah.
Well, there's no point in me just kind
of staring at this for the rest of the
day. Um,
I guess if this string is wrong, maybe
it breaks. Could that be it? That this
string is wrong and then it just breaks.
It doesn't tell you. Silently fails.
I doubt this does anything.
I think this is just it flailing.
Yeah. See, this is just it flailing and
being stupid. Okay. Um,
Go do a little jig and then run a 50k
and then go do uh 2,000 push-ups if
you're
Oh, no.
Guess you can't
Okay,
have a block.
I don't know what the heck to do with
this.
Really don't.
It probably has the source of this
thing, right? That it's not
actually running the command,
but then its fix was dumb, right?
Hey, Joseph. How does pitch?
It's going fairly well. It's just a lot
of time away from other stuff. So, like
when I actually sit down to write code,
I'm basically gigafried.
Um,
and then stuff like this actually
requires a fair bit of thought. So, it's
pretty tough to make progress on all the
things at the same time.
Okay, I'm not going to make any progress
more on this. I'm going to have to
either back fresh or talk to the science
guy or something.
Let me think what other stuff I can do
like actually do today.
Been like out and messed up.
like nine, 10, four or five days in the
past week.
I guess I can let me just take a quick
look at the paper. I've been wanting to
take a look at we can a little bit now
and this R
is
this one step but This is not what we
use.
This is also not even used correctly in
off call.
Oh, hey Finn.
I don't know. I kind of I've been doing
too much stuff this past week. Tough for
me to really get into anything super
heavy at the moment. My mind's kind of
super scattered. How's the drone stuff
going, though?
I got it to the point where like we have
pretty dang good policies on the drones.
Um, we have like pretty dang good
policies on the drones for swarming and
pretty dang good policies for racing. I
couldn't get it to work at the same
time, but we have two policies and
they're both pretty good and they're in
the same sim.
aiming to have simil working like
Okay, awesome.
Yeah, like let me know what you guys
need for me to help with that stuff. I
can technically get myself a drone kit
out to here. I'm going to be at RLC for
a little bit. Obviously,
I definitely want to see Puffer working
on real hardware.
There are a bunch of sort of similar
projects around this space that we can
do if this works as well.
I've had a couple inquiries from drone
people as well.
Is this
Monte Carlo?
But then they have separate stuff, don't
they?
Their results
competitive with SACE.
It's about what we would expect.
The heck is this?
Well, they actually screw up here, don't
they?
Works here. Hard fails here.
motivating thing at the top. doesn't
sense, but
maybe I can look a little bit at the um
the math and just see if I have any
understanding.
Not we'll just do sport stream today and
try to come back fresh
tomorrow or something
to look at it. Yeah.
Kind of too burnt to like fully do this
today, Spencer. But like,
so this motivation thing at the top,
this is garbage evidence.
But then the experiments are good.
not tripping but question on multi.
So I set action space to negative
find them
on multi by set actions. What are you
trying to do different?
I think you can do it that way or you
can or I believe if you set if you set
like tighter bounds then it uh I believe
we have clipping in there somewhere.
Double check for you.
Yeah. So, right here, if you set a
tighter space, it should clip for you.
lat. So, this is actually the thing that
we've been wanting to do like Exactly.
can set the mins and maxes in the box to
be a vector sensor.
Doesn't have to be one number.
Getting interested hyperparameter tuning
on the fly.
Uh
I don't really know if that makes any
sense, Finn.
Like you can technically look at
something like PBT,
but pretty much as far as I know, all
the stuff in that space is pretty janky.
Okay. So
full auxiliary loss.
Okay, so they do actually kind of have
ablations.
It turns out the auxiliary the auxiliary
loss looks like the least important
thing here, right?
Hey, I hope you're doing well. Loved
your tweet by
M's advice. Yeah, it would be my guide.
I put all of my advice for newcomers. I
pretty much have a step by step.
Heck is this
ad bot? Great. Um, all my best advice is
right here.
Link it
where you go to learn stuff.
They say
getting whatever this is and this is a
big thing, right?
And no KL is just like that's trolling
because that's like the core thing. Go.
That's this thing here, right? Oh, is
this here?
This is entropy.
Wait,
average policy entry for KL.
Here's Q. This is ent right
Ah, okay. Hang on. Move the mean squared
error and the critic update
with a cross entropy based loss
function.
Uh, if you're still here, Spencer, this
is a good thing to just try on its own.
This is something I've been wanting to
play with for a while.
It's just a classificationbased loss.
results on a ton of different things.
Very clear, very clearcut.
Makes sense. lines with everything else
I've seen in lit
up to you if you want to do algo side
work. This is what I would probably try
first from uh repo.
I try this first.
Uh if not I will get to it but not
today.
I got a few more messages as well to
look at for us on that side.
I gotta say though, just the number of
meetings I've done lately,
it basically just completely fries me to
the point where I can't do any useful
technical
Well, no. It's like I can do it bet.
It's just that I kind of have to go do
all of one thing, take a break, and then
do all the other thing. I can't just
like swap in and out stuff throughout my
day easily.
I'm perfectly fine at the um
perfectly fine with the social
Burns the heck out of me.
Like honestly the meeting side of things
is way easier.
not hard work and I can put way more
hours into but um problem is it's all
you actually have to build this stuff.
Sounds good. Spencer,
Just no clipping or whatever. Yeah.
Okay. So, that's fine.
But then, let me just see their stuff.
I want to see if this paper is trolling
or not
Okay, so look at this. So pretty much
the vast majority of the performance
increment comes from this HL Gaus thing.
And like our PO is significantly better
than baseline PO.
Like I wouldn't be surprised if this is
where all the PF comes from.
Yeah, this is probably on the ALGO side
like for a relatively simple change.
This is probably the highest value thing
for to look at. Now this doesn't fix our
problems. We actually do need to be able
to do offpaul, but this is this is
probably a highest value thing right now
in RL.
Anybody watching is uh feel can feel
free to take a stab at it. Very easy to
verify whether you have it working or
not. It's just does this thing do better
on most or all of our ends out of the
box?
overwritten.
Oh, that was just temp variable thing,
man.
No, there's that was there was a
question about advantage, but it wasn't
that.
Uhoh. Wait, what is this? Default
networks and propagate the gradient
through.
Oh, this is [ __ ]
Hang on. This paper is [ __ ]
Yeah, this is a weak tuned baseline
classic.
Send this dispenser.
Oh, computing advantage twice. Yeah. So
the reason for that bet is that um we
compute it at the start and then we
recmp compute it across all of the
samples after every update because as
soon as you update the policy all the
advantages change why we have a CUDA
kernel to make sure that's Fast.
How will puffer handle different algos?
Existing M's need to be factored. No,
you don't need to refactor existing M's.
It's basically Tim we just try we try
different algos dev branches and then
what like if an algorithm is just better
across the board that becomes the new
algorithm. The puffer is not going to be
a library of a bunch of different
algorithms. Do our research like we try
to have very high high confidence. We
have the best current algorithm overall.
on policy.
On policy wouldn't really apply as a
term here, but sort of yes.
Well, this is kind of funny.
Where's layer norm?
No, they do have it.
Okay, good.
Wait, what?
importing their own file
binding
I still haven't looked at that
algorithm.
separate. network.
A whole bunch of
fine
Why does it say without and
hyperparameter tuning?
right. Well, we found the skeletons in
the closet.
How feasible do you think having puffer
learn by sight would
you? Yeah, I know. Hydra's
um but we can you can absolutely do
puffer on pixels lower because pixels
are lower.
There's nothing fundamental preventing
you from pixels. You have bindings for
pixel just slow.
All
right. So, paper
poorly controlled baseline. Um,
to their credit, they did tune go a
little bit,
but then also like the vast majority of
the perf here is
no KL isn't like you're going to do KL
obviously.
Um,
but then the like aside from this, the
perf is coming from H.
I don't even think you really need this
Q function at all. Right.
Okay, so this is not exactly what we
need. I think honestly the best thing
from this is just we take Gaus. The rest
of this is kind of whatever.
What else did they do with this
maximum?
That's not clear though, right?
It's like a robotics thing.
Couldn't you get some kind of hardware
that's captured?
Yes.
Can
not an RL problem to do that though.
Destimation.
I don't know why putting this in here
does any
entropy as an exploration mechanism is
very stupid.
because I have enough followers on
Twitter that people just send them to me
from PR.
This is also research.
Okay. So, if we don't have much faith in
maximum entropy RL,
like I I think that the most likely
outcome of this paper is just use HL
Gaus. That's kind of it.
Possibly fiddle with layerorm
though layer sucks.
But more than anything, yes, also the
other nice thing from this paper is
uh this auxiliary loss
sometimes does something but sometimes
not really.
Auxiliary loss is not like this
self-supervised objective is not the
magic bullet. At
Well, I mean, this was relatively
productive, right? Because I think of
everything I've seen, this is like the
bit that I have the highest confidence
actually does something.
Honestly,
of everything I've seen. Now, apparently
there is a little bit of a tricky thing
with getting Gaussian samples to fast
and torch or whatever, but
this is definitely worth doing here. I
don't know about the rest of this paper
there. it like it really doesn't even do
all the stuff that we would want.
Anyways, I guess it does get you a Q
function that's stable, right? A Q
function based formulation that's stable
accent RL's kind of
time. Is it is it 3:20?
All
right.
So,
I think I'm just going to call it for
now. Frankly,
there anything else I can do?
Better to just call it and do other
stuff for a bit today.
material science sim bothers me that I
haven't been able to get something
working on this yet, but like
probably just going to commit this
science friend
if he can what I've done wrong with it.
All right. Well, thank you folks. I will
try to be back fresh um time as in the
next few days to actually get some cool
stuff done either implementing this or
doing some probe environments or any
number of other things.
Uh so for folks who are watching
hopper.ai for all the things start the
GitHub to help us out. It's free.
Discord, get involved with dev.